Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. The topic for this episode is dopamine. It's known as the chemical of love, sex, creativity, and addiction. Dopamine always wants more. It pushes us to achieve greatness, but can also lead to our downfall. Our guests for this episode are Dr. Dan Lieberman, Professor and Vice Chair for Clinical Affairs and Department of Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences at the George Washington University,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目的主题是多巴胺。它被称为爱、性、创造力和成瘾的化学物质。多巴胺总是想要更多。它推动我们追求卓越，但也可能导致我们的堕落。本期节目的嘉宾是乔治华盛顿大学精神病学与行为科学系临床事务副主席、教授丹·利伯曼博士，
and Mike Long, a speechwriter, screenwriter and playwright who teaches writing at Georgetown University. They co-wrote a book called The Molecule of Moore, How a Single Chemical in Your Brain Drives Love, Sex, Creativity, and will determine the fate of the human race. Welcome, Dr. Lieberman and Mr. Long. Thank you. Happy to have you on the show. Yeah. So I'm sure many of our listeners have heard of dopamine, but may not know exactly what it is and exactly what it does.
以及乔治城大学写作课讲师、演讲稿撰写人、编剧兼剧作家迈克·朗。他们合著了一本书，名为《多巴胺分子：大脑中的单一化学物质如何驱动爱、性、创造力，并决定人类的命运》。欢迎利伯曼博士和朗先生。谢谢。很高兴邀请到你们参加节目。是的。我相信我们的许多听众都听说过多巴胺，但可能并不确切知道它是什么，也不确切知道它有什么作用。
So Dr. Lieberman, can you start off with a very basic question? What exactly is dopamine? Dopamine's a chemical in the brain. I like to think of it like the conductor of an orchestra. It turns on, turns off, turns up the volume, turns down the volume on a lot of different areas in the brain. And as a result, it has an outside, an outsized influence on our behavior. Everything in our body serves a purpose. So from evolutionary perspective, why does dopamine exist in our brains and are we the only animals who have dopamine. When people think about dopamine, they often think about reward. And that is an important aspect of it. We get feelings of pleasure, reinforcement, even euphoria, when we do things that promote our survival and our reproduction, eating food, drinking water, winning competitions,
那么利伯曼博士，您能先从一个非常基本的问题开始吗？多巴胺到底是什么？多巴胺是大脑中的一种化学物质。我喜欢把它想象成管弦乐队的指挥。它开启、关闭、调大或调小大脑中许多不同区域的音量。因此，它对我们的行为有着巨大的影响。我们身体里的每一件事物都有其目的。那么从进化的角度来看，为什么我们的大脑中会有多巴胺？我们是唯一拥有多巴胺的动物吗？当人们想到多巴胺时，通常会想到奖励。这是它的一个重要方面。当我们做一些促进生存和繁衍的事情时，比如吃东西、喝水、赢得比赛，我们会感到快乐、强化，甚至欣快，
and having sex. So from an evolutionary point of view, it's incredibly important. And that's why it's so powerful because it directs our behavior from the bottom up. It's designed to keep us alive and make us evolutionarily successful. So it's really been integral in what has helped us evolve from early humans to where we are today. It's true. And most animals do have it. It's a very ancient chemical, but humans seem to have more of it than any other organism. And we are much more sophisticated than other organisms. And so in human beings, it does a lot more than just reward us when we engage in pro-survival activities. It's responsible for a whole host of activities that people would never guess, such as love, creativity, even political affiliation. So, before you're
以及进行性行为。所以从进化的角度来看，它极其重要。这就是它如此强大的原因，因为它从底层引导我们的行为。它的设计初衷是让我们活下去，并使我们在进化上取得成功。因此，它确实是我们从早期人类进化到今天这一过程不可或缺的一部分。确实如此。大多数动物都有它。这是一种非常古老的化学物质，但人类似乎比任何其他生物拥有更多的多巴胺。而且我们比其他生物复杂得多。因此，在人类身上，它不仅仅是在我们进行生存活动时奖励我们，它还负责许多人们意想不到的活动，例如爱、创造力，甚至是政治倾向。所以，在您刚才
talking about animals. So would something like a distant relative of ours like a primate have dopamine? And would something simple like an earthworm have dopamine? You know, I don't know about earthworms. It's your next book. Yeah, that's right. Primates definitely have them. You may be surprised to learn the animal that has the most of it. And that is ravens, crows, blackbirds.
谈到动物时。那么像我们远亲的灵长类动物会有多巴胺吗？像蚯蚓这样简单的生物会有多巴胺吗？你知道，我不知道蚯蚓的情况。那是你们的下一本书。是的，没错。灵长类动物肯定有。你可能会惊讶地发现，拥有最多多巴胺的动物是渡鸦、乌鸦和黑鹂。
Yeah. They're actually incredibly good at solving problems, better even than chimpanzees. They've done experiments in which they've put together a problem for a raven to solve. It involves getting a piece of food. And it involves multi-steps. they've got to build a tool and then use the tool to get the food and they're able to do it. And we think it's because they've got so much dopamine. That's fascinating.
是的。它们实际上非常擅长解决问题，甚至比黑猩猩还要好。他们做过实验，为渡鸦设置了一个需要解决的问题。这涉及到获取食物。而且涉及多个步骤。它们必须制造工具，然后使用工具获取食物，它们能够做到。我们认为这是因为它们拥有大量的多巴胺。这太迷人了。
I think this begins to open the door on what we think is so interesting about the book. Dopamine obviously has this evolutionary role and it has fulfilled it well. And to this point, it's great. But here we are in a modern age where a lot of the things that it was required for in a raw, empty place, we don't have that problem anymore. We don't have to worry about where the next meal is coming from in most of the world. We don't have to worry about where we're going to sleep tonight and who we're going to sleep with, frankly. There are mechanisms in civilization to find that person. And yet dopamine remains, and correct me if I'm wrong, Dan, at the same
我认为这开始揭示了我们认为这本书如此有趣的原因。多巴胺显然具有这种进化作用，而且它完成得很好。到目前为止，这很棒。但我们现在处于一个现代时代，在原始、空旷的环境中所需的许多东西，我们不再有这个问题了。在世界大部分地区，我们不必担心下一顿饭从哪里来。坦率地说，我们不必担心今晚睡在哪里，也不必担心和谁一起睡。文明中有找到那个人的机制。然而多巴胺依然存在，如果我错了请纠正我，丹，它依然保持在
levels it's always been, more or less. Here we go. And dopamine has to have something to do. And that leads to these cultural effects, these cultural conflicts, these personal experiences that are sometimes frustrating, sometimes curious and strange. And that's where we went with the book, is understanding how dopamine got us to this point, how it explains so much trouble we find ourselves in today and so many curious experiences we have. I think perhaps the broadest way to describe dopamine is that it's designed to maximize future resources. And, and, and, and, And we can see that working in ourselves when we are constantly focused on the future. I need more.
一直以来的水平，或多或少。就是这样。多巴胺必须有事可做。这就导致了这些文化影响、这些文化冲突、这些有时令人沮丧、有时好奇而奇怪的个人经历。这就是我们写这本书的初衷，了解多巴胺是如何把我们带到这一点的，它如何解释我们今天发现自己陷入的许多麻烦，以及我们拥有的许多好奇经历。我认为描述多巴胺最广泛的方式可能是，它的设计初衷是最大化未来的资源。而且，我们可以看到它在我们不断关注未来时在起作用。我需要更多。
I'm not satisfied. I'm not a good enough person. Rather than just kind of taking a deep breath and saying, wow, look at all the wonderful things I have, the good things I've done. I'm grateful for them. Dopamine doesn't want us to do that. It wants to keep us constantly on the run. Dopamine sets us up to appreciate the world, to experience the world in two ways. And for me, this was a revelatory.
我不满足。我不是一个足够好的人。而不是深吸一口气说，哇，看看我拥有的所有美好事物，我所做的善事。我对此心存感激。多巴胺不希望我们这样做。它希望让我们不断奔跑。多巴胺让我们以两种方式欣赏世界，体验世界。对我来说，这具有启示意义。
We have things that we appreciate, the color of your top right now, the color of the walls of the room, the feel of this table, the taste of the cup of water here I have, things that we experience in the moment. We appreciate what they're like. That's one way we spend our time. The other way we spend our time is anticipating, planning, looking forward to, thinking about things that have yet to occur. And that's a different kind of pleasure. And dopamine is the conductor of that pleasure. And once you begin to divide the world, divide your experience, divide your personal experiences into those two categories, dopamine's role rises to the fore. It becomes obvious that there are different ways we move through the day and different reasons we are motivated. Some are more motivated by things in the future, things we're working toward. Some are motivated by how beautiful this is or what the experience is like and they're very different things. Yeah, I found that very fascinating in the book. You were talking about how dopamine is that initial chemical that floods your brain when you spot something novel or new, but that it does fade.
我们有欣赏的事物，比如你现在的上衣颜色、房间墙壁的颜色、这张桌子的触感、我这里这杯水的味道，这些是我们当下体验的事物。我们欣赏它们的样子。这是我们度过时间的一种方式。我们度过时间的另一种方式是期待、计划、展望、思考尚未发生的事情。那是另一种快乐。而多巴胺就是这种快乐的指挥。一旦你开始划分世界，划分你的体验，将你的个人经历分为这两类，多巴胺的作用就会凸显出来。显而易见，我们度过一天的方式不同，我们被激励的原因也不同。有些人更多地被未来的事物、我们正在努力实现的目标所激励。有些人则被事物的美丽或体验本身所激励，它们是非常不同的事情。是的，我在书中发现了这一点非常迷人。你谈到多巴胺是如何在你发现新奇事物时最初涌入大脑的化学物质，但它确实会消退。
And in the context of love, which is an integral part of your book, dopamine is that chemical that when you fall in love, you feel euphoric and you just want to walk down the street singing and dancing. Because that's what dopamine does. It says, here's something new. There might be something useful in this that'll help me in the future, help me reproduce or keep me safe or whatever it is. In the case of loves, my goodness, look at this possibility. It's right in front of me, and you get this euphoria. And the more you learn about the thing, the less there is to explore, the dopamine begins to fade. It makes a promise that other senses would have or other chemicals would have to keep.
在爱的背景下，这是你书中的一个组成部分，多巴胺就是那种当你坠入爱河时，你会感到欣快，只想走在街上唱歌跳舞的化学物质。因为这就是多巴胺的作用。它说，这里有新东西。这其中可能有对我未来有用的东西，能帮助我繁衍、保护我安全或任何其他事情。在爱的情况下，天哪，看看这个可能性。它就在我面前，你得到了这种欣快感。你对这件事了解得越多，需要探索的东西就越少，多巴胺就开始消退。它做出了其他感官或其他化学物质必须兑现的承诺。
Yeah, that's also what I want to touch on too. You said, so, you know, the initial fall in love feeling, however long that might last for a specific person, it's probably up to the individual. But, you know, if that might taper off six to eight months a year. And then you need those other chemicals in your brain, neurotransmars, I believe, to basically take you to that next phase of making love last. And those you coined here and now molecules. So can you talk a little bit about that
是的，这也是我想触及的。你说，你知道，最初坠入爱河的感觉，无论对特定的人持续多久，这可能取决于个人。但是，你知道，如果那可能在六到八个月或一年内逐渐减弱。然后你需要大脑中的其他化学物质，我相信是神经递质，来基本上带你进入让爱持久的下一个阶段。而你把这些称为“此时此地”分子。所以你能谈谈那个吗？
and how those are important for keeping relationships alive? Sure. So dopamine is all about the future, making the future better, maximizing resources. It gives us desire and anticipation. But as Mike pointed out, it makes promises it can't keep. So, for example, you may be wanting a brand new TV and going on the internet, getting all
以及它们对于维持关系的重要性？当然。所以多巴胺完全是关于未来的，让未来变得更好，最大化资源。它给我们欲望和期待。但正如迈克指出的那样，它做出了它无法兑现的承诺。例如，你可能想要一台全新的电视，上网搜索，对那台电视感到兴奋。但一旦你得到了它，事情就变了，因为它已经从未来变成了现在。而多巴胺只能处理未来。所以发生的事情是多巴胺关闭了。这就是买家悔恨的原因之一，每个人都听说过。是的。可能也经历过。是的。
excited about that TV. But as soon as you get it, things change because it's gone from the future to the present. And dopamine can only process the future. So what happens is dopamine shuts down. And that's one of the causes of buyer's remorse, which everybody has heard of. Yeah. An experience probably too. Yeah.
不幸的是，爱也是如此。我们从房间对面看到某人，突然我们开始幻想他们有多完美。这个人是我梦寐以求的人。他们会改变我的生活。这与现实完全无关。而且，你知道，每个治疗师都要处理有这个问题的病人。他们遇到新的人。他们变得非常兴奋。
And the same thing happens with love, unfortunately. we see someone from across the room and all of a sudden we start developing fantasies about how perfect they are. This person is my dream person. They're going to change my life. It has absolutely nothing to do with reality. And, you know, every therapist deals with patients who have this problem. They meet somebody new. They get all excited.
他们说，就是这个人了。然后一旦他们了解了那个人，一旦那个人从他们想象中的欲望对象变成了真实的人，他们就完全失去了兴趣。他们去找治疗师说，为什么我不能维持长期关系？答案是多巴胺。他们无法从那种多巴胺能的希望和期待中转移到“此时此地”。
They say, this is the one. And then as soon as they get to know that person, as soon as the person changes from an object of desire in their imagination, to a real human being, they completely lose interest. And they go to their therapist and they say, how come I can't have long-term relationships? The answer is dopamine. They're not able to transfer from that dopaminergic hope and anticipation into the here and now.
那么这些化学物质是什么？对于爱，可能最重要的化学物质是催产素。这是许多人都听说过的化学物质。它有时被称为“拥抱化学物质”。基本上它的作用是让我们面向关系。它在实验中通过鼻内给药，使人们对他们视为自己群体一部分的人产生温暖、亲密的感觉。
So what are these chemicals? For love, probably the most important chemical is oxytocin. That's a chemical many people have heard of. It's sometimes called the cuddle chemical. basically what it does is it orientes us towards relationships. It's been administered intranasally in experiments, and it makes people have warm feelings, close feelings, to people that they count as part of their group.
那是可以持久的东西。多巴胺能的爱被称为激情之爱，那是坠入爱河的感觉，那种对另一个人几乎疯狂的激情，无限的乐观，一切都是积极的。可能的。这持续大约九到十二个月。好的。然后你必须转移。方便，九个月。许多婴儿出生。在这期间。是的。然后你转移到所谓的伴侣之爱。那是可以持续一生的爱。而这更多是由化学物质驱动的
That's something that can last. Dopaminergic love has been called passionate love, and that's the feeling of being in love, that almost insane feeling of passion for the other person, unbounded optimism, anything is positive. possible. That lasts about nine to 12 months. Okay. And then you got to transfer over. Convenient, nine months. Many babies are born. During the time. Yeah. Then you transfer over to what's called companion at love. That's the kind of love that can last a lifetime. And that's more driven by chemicals
比如催产素和血清素。这太重要了。我说我把它投射到别人身上。我知道，但当我学习这些材料时，再次对我来说是一个启示，看到当你谈论爱时，你谈论的是两件非常不同的事情。你谈论的是浪漫阶段或激情阶段，然后你谈论的是伴侣阶段。我们当中有些人永远无法逃离浪漫阶段，这听起来很令人兴奋，直到你想到这真正意味着什么。我们在书中使用的例子，我们用了两个例子。
like oxytocin and serotonin. It's so important. And I say that I'm projecting it on to other people. I know, but as I learned this material, it was, again, just such a revelation for me to see that when you talk about love, you're talking about two very different things. You're talking about the romantic phase or the passionate phase, and then you're talking about the companionate phase. And there are those of us who never escape the romantic phase, which sounds kind of exciting until you think about what that really means. The example we use in the book, we use two examples.
一个是米克·贾格尔，一个是乔治·科斯坦扎，从这个人的角度来看，他们实际上是同一个人。当我们听到这种比较时，这听起来非常令人震惊。乔治·科斯坦扎就是某种秃头的米克·贾格尔。贾格尔告诉他的传记作者，他在职业生涯中与4000名女性有过交往。顺便说一句，这赋予了“我无法获得满足”新的含义。可以肯定地说，一个在
One is Mick Jagger and one is George Costanza, who, it turns out from this person. perspective are exactly the same person. Which sounds just kind of shocking when we hear that in comparison. George Costanza is sort of a balding McJagger is what we get there. Jagger told his biographer that he had been with 4,000 women over the course of his career. So it gives a new meaning to you. I can't get no satisfaction, by the way. And it's pretty safe to say that an individual who is going through 4,000 people over the
几十年里经历了4000人的人，我想我们算出来是每两周一个，就是那个，每两周一次邂逅。任何那样生活的人在爱的领域里都是完全彻底的多巴胺能。一旦他们遇到某人，那是一个谜，一个奇迹，然后一旦那个谜团被解开一点点，他们就不再感兴趣了。科斯坦扎也是一样。他只是没有米克·贾格尔那种傲慢。你记得，每当他遇到一个女人，他都认为这就是那个“对的人”。他爱上了那个女人。他为那个词“爱”而疯狂。他说，爱上了那个，为那个女人而疯狂。这就是那个“对的人”，直到他和她出去几次。然后他不得不让自己脱身。
course of a few decades, I think we came up with one every two weeks, was what that, that one encounter every two weeks. Anybody who's living like that is dopaminergic completely and utterly in the realm of love. As soon as they meet somebody, it's a mystery, it's a wonder, and then as soon as the least bit of that mystery is solved, they're not interested anymore. And Costanza is the same way. He just doesn't have the swagger of Mick Jagger. You remember, that whenever he met a woman, he thought this was the one. He was in love with that woman. He was crazy for that word love. He said, in love with that was crazy for that woman. This was the one right up until he went out with her a few times. And then he had to extricate himself.
他在这一方面太糟糕了，以至于当他，当他找到最终同意嫁给他的女人时，他因为自己这样做而感到厌恶。当她在那个著名的剧集中因为舔毒信封而死时。他没有崩溃或悲伤。他感到解脱。他感到解脱。现在，你知道，说这有点夸张很容易，我想从戏剧的角度来看确实如此，但我们认识那些人。他们拼命想进入一段关系，一旦进入，他们就拼命想逃出来，因为爱有两种，浪漫和陪伴。并不是每个人都能完成那种转变，因为这是一个你做出的选择。我会说，看，我明白我无法在浪漫中找到满足。
He was so awful in this way that when he, when he found the woman who finally agreed to marry him, he was disgusted with himself for having done it. And when she died from licking the poison envelopes in that famous episode. He was not crushed or sad. He was relieved. He was relieved. Now, it's, you know, it's easy to say that's a little hyperbolic, and I suppose it is from a dramatic perspective, but we know those people. They're desperate to get in a relationship, and as soon as they're in it, they're desperate to get out, because there are two kinds of love, the romance and the companionship. And not everybody makes that transition because it's a choice you make. am I going to say, look, I understand I can't find satisfaction and romance.
我要把它作为一种伴侣关系来经营。所以这是一个有意识的选择。绝对是。好的。所以这不是那种自然而然就会转变的事情？我不完全是。是的。别让我在这里操之过急。
I'm going to work on this as a companionate relationship. So that's a conscious choice. Absolutely. Okay. So it's not something it just kind of turns over? I'm not exactly. Yeah. Don't let me get out in front of my skis here.
是的，继续。我不认为这是一个有意识的选择。我认为这是成熟的标志，是需要努力的事情。能够远离那种刺激、兴奋，说，我想要一些更持久、更长久的东西。我有一个病人，他和乔治·科斯坦扎/米克·贾格尔非常相似，这个形象我将无法从脑海中抹去。一个混合体。
Yeah, go ahead. I don't think it is a conscious choice. I think it's something that is a sign of maturity and that one has to work on. The ability to step away from the thrill, the excitement, and say, I want something more enduring, longer lasting. I had a patient who was very similar to George Costanza slash Mick Jagger, an image, which I will not be able to get out of my mind. A mashup.
他有过数百个女朋友。她很冷，杰瑞。她是金子。她不是，我想。继续。他有过数百个女朋友。就像不再从毒品中获得快感，但必须继续吸食的可卡因成瘾者一样，
And he had had hundreds of girlfriends. She's cold, Jerry. She's gold. She's not, I guess. Go ahead. He had hundreds of girlfriends. And like the cocaine addict, who no longer gets pleasure from the drug, but has to keep doing it,
他不再从这些邂逅中获得快感，但他因为某种原因无法过渡到伴侣阶段。所以有一天，他遇到了一个女孩，和她约会了几周，然后说服她和他一起去拉斯维加斯结婚。因为他认为他可以控制这种情况。他会娶她，从此过上幸福的生活，但结果并不如意。是的，这并不完全令人惊讶。但我猜这引出的一个问题是，不同的人大脑中是否有不同数量的多巴胺，从而影响这种行为？确实有。确实有。很大一部分是遗传的。哦，有趣。是的。有
he was no longer getting pleasure from these. counters, but he couldn't make that transition for one reason or another to the companion phase. So one day, he met a girl, dated her for a couple weeks, and then persuaded her to come to Las Vegas with him and get married. Because he thought that he could take control of this situation. He'd get married to her and live happily ever after, and it did not work out. Yes, that's not totally surprising. But I guess one question that this leads me to is, do different people have different amounts of dopamine in their brains that could influence this type of behavior? They do. They do. A large part of it is genetic. Oh, interesting. Yeah. There are
细胞上有被称为多巴胺受体的蛋白质，它们对化学物质多巴胺做出反应，并因此改变细胞的功能。其中一些比其他的更敏感。大脑中还有其他结构也是由基因决定的，对多巴胺有更强或更弱的影响。这些与特定类型的个性相关联。好的。有不同的例子。是的，当然。大脑中有不同的多巴胺通路。
there are proteins on the cell called dopamine receptors that react to the chemical dopamine and change the functioning of the cell as a result. Some of these are more sensitive than others. And there's other structures in their brain as well that are genetically determined to have a stronger or weaker effect to dopamine. And these are associated with particular kinds of personalities. Okay. There's different example. Yeah, sure. There's different dopamine tracks in the brain.
根据哪一个特别活跃，我们可以看到这种对未来痴迷的不同表现。例如，有一条被称为中脑边缘通路的通路，我们在书中称之为“欲望通路”。如果你有一个非常强大的欲望通路，你就有可能对毒品上瘾。你会不断地追求快感。那就是你会得到更多、更多、更多的地方。
And depending on which one is particularly active, we can see different manifestations of this obsession with the future. So, for example, there is a track called the mesolimbic track, which we in the book called the desire pathway. And if you've got a very strong desire pathway, you're going to be at risk of becoming addicted to drugs. You're going to be constantly pursuing pleasure. that's where you're going to get your more, more, more.
不过，还有另一条通往额叶的通路。我们称之为“控制通路”。与更注重即时满足的欲望通路相反，它为长期收益做计划。因此，拥有非常强大的控制系统的人会更倾向于A型工作狂。他们无法放松。他们工作极其努力。他们是那种买得起海滩别墅却无法享受的人，
There's another pathway, though, that goes up to the frontal lobes. We call that the control pathway. As opposed to the desire pathway, which is more immediate gratification, this plans for longer-term gain. And so people with very strong control systems are going to be more the type A workaholics. They can't relax. They work incredibly hard. They're the kind of people who can afford beach houses but can't enjoy.
因为他们最做不到的事情就是坐在海滩上享受阳光。多巴胺能非常强的人可能会患上精神疾病，如双相情感障碍和精神分裂症。然后，令人惊讶的是，与此密切相关的是非常有创造力的人。音乐家、演员、作家，他们也可能拥有非常高水平的多巴胺。这就是为什么我们在这一人群中看到对精神疾病的某种更高的易感性。我想回到你使用的一个短语，这对于理解这一点非常关键，如果你能记住这个短语，那就是多巴胺驱动对快感的追求。
them because the last thing they're going to be able to do is sit on the beach soaking up the sun. Very, very highly dopamine urge people can have mental illnesses such as bipolar disorder and schizophrenia. And then very closely related to that, surprisingly, are very creative people. People who are musicians, actors, writers, they can also have very high levels of dopamine. and that's why we see in this population a somewhat higher vulnerability to mental illness. I want to roll back just to a phrase you use that's so key to understanding this, if you can hold on to the phrase, and that is dopamine driving the pursuit of pleasure.
结论是追求，而不是快感。它承诺如果你做这些事情，如果你做所有这些繁重的脑力劳动，你最终会得到快感。多巴胺在字面上没有能力以任何方式给你那种快感。那必须由“此时此地”的神经递质提供。所以它整天都在承诺。你雄心勃勃地说，你为什么工作？我工作是为了成功，为了获得巨大的快感和伟大的事物。
The takeaway is pursuit, not pleasure. It promises that if you do these things, if you do all this heavy mental lifting, you will have pleasure at the end. Dopamine is literally unequipped to give you that pleasure in any way. That has to be provided by the here and now neurotransmitters. So it promises all day long. You're ambitious to say, why do you work? I'll work so I can be successful, so I can have great pleasure and great things.
找到那个说这话的人，看看他是否真的在享受这些东西。就像你说的关于海滩别墅，买得起它的人并不是那个会享受它的人。这就是多巴胺的作用。它让你踏上旅程，承诺那里。终点有巨大的奖励，但它对那一点无能为力。如果你没有能力参与那种体验，那种欣赏，你就不会快乐。有一句古老的谚语：旅行充满希望比到达更好。
Find the person who says that who's actually enjoying those things. Like you said about the beach house, the one who can afford it is not the one who will enjoy it. That's what dopamine does. It sends you on the trip promising that there. There are great rewards at the end, but it can't do anything about that. And if you're not equipped to engage in that experience, in that appreciation, you're not going to be happy. There's an old saying to travel hopefully is better than to arrive.
是一样的。你听说过吗？不，我没有。但我喜欢那个。这是多巴胺的同一件事。它确实是一把双刃剑。如果旅行充满希望是令人愉快的，它会给你完成事情的动力和激励。
That's the same. Have you heard that? No, I haven't. I like that, though. It's a same thing of dopamine. And it's very much a double-edged sword. If traveling hopefully is enjoyable, it's going to give you the motivation and the incentive to get things done.
但当你到达时，一切都结束了。所以你可以努力工作，但你永远无法享受你为之努力的东西。我要说的是。我认为我们之间的区别在于程度不同。写这本书很有趣。我们很享受。我们有有趣的意见分歧。我们有愚蠢的争论。
But then when you arrive, it's all over. And so you can work hard, but you can never enjoy what you've worked for. I'm going to say this. And I think the difference between us is one of degrees. Writing this book was a lot of fun. We enjoyed it. We had fun disagreements. We had silly arguments.
我们进行了严肃的讨论。我要说，就我而言，写这本书比把它拿在手里更有趣。我的意思是，我为它感到自豪，我学到了很多。但我们经历的那两年过程，我不会用任何东西来交换。这仅仅是经历那个过程的体验。是的。这很好。我想触及你提到的关于成瘾的问题。
We had serious discussions. And I'm going to say, for my part, writing the book was a lot more fun than having it in your hand. I mean, I'm proud of it and I learned a lot. But that two-year course we went through, I wouldn't trade that for anything. And it was simply the experience of going through that. Yeah. It was good. And I wanted to touch on what you mentioned about addiction.
所以成瘾，我们现在一直在听到这个，特别是在像阿片类药物这样的硬毒品方面。这是我们国家对话的一部分。显然，今天有许多人对毒品上瘾。多巴胺在成瘾中扮演什么角色？在这个领域关于多巴胺的研究有什么进展？多巴胺确实是成瘾的本质。任何潜在成瘾的药物都会导致多巴胺的释放，导致多巴胺在那个欲望回路中的活动。
So addictions, we're hearing about this all the time now, especially with hard drugs like opioids. It's part of our national conversation. Many people, obviously, today are addicted to drugs. And what role does dopamine play in addiction? and has there, what has been the research in this area about dopamine? Really, dopamine is the essence of addiction. Any drug that's potentially addictive is going to cause the release of dopamine, the activity of dopamine in that desire circuit.
反之亦然，任何导致这种多巴胺活动的物质都会让人上瘾。前段时间关于大麻是否会让人上瘾有很多争论。它会。是的。现在我们看到这些非常高浓度的品种可用，我们有很多，我们发现人们正在失去对大麻使用的控制，但阿片类药物、可卡因，这会导致更多的多巴胺释放，所以这些极易上瘾。某些导致多巴胺释放的行为也可能失控。
And conversely, any substance which causes this dopamine activity is going to be addictive. There was a lot of debate some time ago about whether or not marijuana could be addictive. It can. Yeah. And now that we're seeing these very high potent strains available, we have a lot of, we have a lot of we are finding people who are losing control of their marijuana use, but opioids, cocaine, this causes a lot more dopamine release, and so these are extremely addictive. There are certain behaviors that cause dopamine release that also can get out of control.
我不认为关于我们是否要称之为成瘾已经达成共识，但像视频游戏、消费色情制品，这些看起来非常像成瘾。是的，这似乎世界上有各种各样的诱惑。也许一直都有，但在我们的现代时代，似乎有太多了。而这正是多巴胺想要承诺的，你会享受这些东西。当你发现自己陷入对某种药物上瘾的循环中，或者像你说的，其中一些东西，他们今天还在研究这是否是一种真正的成瘾。但视频游戏、色情制品，那种东西。这确实是真正可以占据主导地位的东西。是的，没错。
I don't think if there's a consensus yet about whether we're going to call it addiction, but things like video games, consuming pornography, these are things that look very much like addiction. Yeah, it just sort of seems like there's all these temptations. out there in the world. Maybe there always has been, but in our modern age, there seems to be so many. And that's really what dopamine wants to promise that you'll enjoy these things. And when you find yourself trapped in the cycle of being addicted to a drug or whether it's, like you said, some of these things, they're still figuring out today whether it's an actual addiction. But video games, pornography, that kind of thing. Just this is of something that really can take hold. Yes, that's right.
你知道，在过去，我们过去认为成瘾是身体依赖。也就是说，某人会产生耐受性。他们需要越来越多才能获得同样的效果。或者如果他们停止使用，他们会有戒断反应。所以我们过去通过排毒来治疗成瘾。我们认为如果我们能把所有的毒品从体内排出，让他们干净清醒地离开，他们就会有一个新的开始，但这并没有奏效。是的，因为那不是多巴胺的作用。
You know, in the old days, we used to think about addiction as physical dependence. That is that somebody would get tolerance. They'd need more and more to get the same effect. Or they'd have withdrawal if they stop using it. And so we used to treat addiction through detoxification. We thought if we can get all the drug out of the body, send them out clean and sober, they'd have a fresh start, and it did not work. Yeah, because that's not what dopamine does.
多巴胺不仅在你使用毒品时给你快感，更重要的是，它给你渴望。而渴望才是成瘾的本质。我们都知道那是什么感觉。你知道，你说，我要开始一个新的锻炼计划。我要把闹钟提前30分钟。闹钟响了，你渴望睡眠。是的，没人想起床。
Dopamine not only gives you pleasure when you use the drug, but more important, it gives you craving. And it's craving that's the essence of addiction. And we all know what that feels like. You know, you say, I'm going to start a new exercise routine. I'm going to set my alarm clock for 30 minutes early. The alarm goes off and you crave sleep. Yes, no one to get off.
这种体验实际上削弱了自由意志。它并没有完全夺走它。人们仍然有选择，但它使做出正确的选择变得困难得多。因为我们对大脑的生物活动做出反应，而多巴胺在这方面非常非常强大。丹，你能谈谈吗，我记得当我们工作时这第一次出现，你从逻辑的角度谈论它，这是另一个，我正在把这个词用烂，但这是另一个启示，我从你那里学到的关于这个的东西，是它不再那么关于渴望，而是，好吧，这是正确的事情。这是明智的事情。我牺牲这些东西来获得这种毒品的快感是合乎逻辑的。你怎么能有别的想法？
And the experience is that it actually diminishes free will. It does not take it away completely. People still have a choice, but it makes making the right choice so much more difficult. because we respond to the biological activity of our brain, and dopamine is very, very powerful in that respect. Dan, would you talk about, I remember when this first came up when we were working, and you talked about it in terms of logic, which was another, I'm wearing this word out, but it was another revelation for me, the thing that I learned from you about this, was that it ceases to be about craving so much as, well, this is the right thing to do. This is a smart thing to do. It's logical that I would sacrifice these things to get the hit of this drug. How could you think otherwise?
你能展开谈谈那个想法吗？是的，那是一个很好的观点。你知道，当我们看到瘾君子时，假设我们看到一个无家可归的酒鬼，他在街上，手里拿着一个棕色纸袋里的瓶子。他放弃了他的家庭、工作、家、健康。他放弃了一切来消费这种毒品。我们从外面看，这似乎完全不合理。为什么有人会为了喝酒而毁掉自己的生活？从内部看，
Can you expand on that idea a little bit? Yeah, that's a great point. You know, when we see the addict, let's say that we see an alcoholic who's homeless, he's down on the street, he's got a bottle in a brown paper bag. He's given up his family, his job, his home, his health. He's given up everything in order to consume this drug. We look at from the outside, it seems utterly. irrational. Why would somebody destroy their life just so that they can drink? From the inside,
虽然，这实际上非常合理，因为你必须记住，这些回路是进化设计的，目的是让我们活下去并使我们成功。毒品的问题在于它们给多巴胺系统带来了这种化学冲击，几乎就像一枚制导导弹，导致比自然行为更多的多巴胺刺激。大脑根据它们产生多少多巴胺来对行为进行评级。所以赚一百万美元产生的多巴胺比赚10美元多。所以你会去追求那个大的回报。使用毒品产生的多巴胺比供养你的孩子多。所以我们仍然可以使用大脑的不同部分来说，嘿，那是错的。但我们的动机系统在逻辑上告诉我们，使用毒品更有意义。是的，我们显然，很多人经常看
though, it's actually very rational because you have to remember that these circuits were designed by evolution to keep us alive and make us successful. The problem with drugs is they give this chemical blast to the dopamine system, almost like a guided missile that causes more dopamine stimulation than natural behaviors. The brain rates behaviors based on how much dopamine they produce. So earning a million dollars produces more dopamine than earning $10. So you're going to go after that big payoff. Using drugs produces more dopamine than providing for your children. And so we can still use different parts of our brains to say, hey, that's wrong. But our motivation system is telling us logically it makes more sense to use the drug. Yeah, we obviously, a lot of people often look
成瘾是由于道德缺陷、缺乏意志力、人格缺陷等等。但你写道，多巴胺是人们对事物上瘾的主要因素。正如你所说的，这不仅仅是关于排毒，而是关于渴望。而且是关于你的大脑不断想要你回到你正在使用的东西。在你的书中，你写道克服成瘾需要巨大的力量、决心和支持。所以你能再解释一下吗？为什么多巴胺让戒除成瘾变得如此困难？你知道，为什么它把人们带回来？这就是从内部与外部观察到的有趣行为。
at addiction as due to moral failings, lack of willpower, personality flaws, you name it. But you wrote that dopamine is a major factor why people get addicted to things. And as you're saying it, it's not just about detoxing, it's about the cravings. And it's about your brain constantly wanting you to go back to what you were using. And in your book, you wrote how overcoming addiction takes enormous strength determination and support. So can you explain again? Why does dopamine, make it so hard to kick an addiction. You know, why does it bring people back? And that's the interesting behavior from the inside versus the outside.
从外部看，它确实看起来像道德缺陷。看起来人们只是在使用非常糟糕的判断力，或者他们沉溺于自己，沉溺于他们对快感的渴望。但从内部看，它非常非常不同。他们有那种压倒性的渴望感。如果我们从那个角度来看，从大脑行为来看，我们可以把它看作一种医学疾病，我们可以使用医学治疗来解决它。简单的事实是，医学治疗非常成功。心理治疗是最重要的一种。我们也有药物可以
From the outside, it does look like a moral failing. It looks like people are just using very bad judgment or they're indulging themselves, their desire for pleasure. From the inside, though, it's very, very different. They've got these feelings of overwhelming cravings. If we look at it from that point of view, from brain behavior, we can look at it as a medical illness and we can use medical treatments to address it. And the simple fact is that medical treatments are extremely successful. Psychotherapy is the most important one. We also have medications that can
增加心理治疗成功的可能性。如果你只是把它看作一种道德缺陷，你根本不会有太大的成功。我认为这就是为什么变得稍微复杂一点如此重要。超越仅仅对行为做出解释，问问自己，大脑中发生了什么，我们如何克服这种病态的大脑行为？你认为这就是这个国家关于如何治疗成瘾的对话方向吗？我想是这样。我认为仍然存在巨大的污名。总的来说，大脑疾病与其他疾病相比受到更多的污名化。但我们正在取得进展。你可能太年轻了，不记得了，但曾经有一段时间，患癌症是受到污名化的。
increase the likelihood of success of psychotherapy. If you just look at it as a moral failing, you're just not going to have a lot of success. And I think that's why it's so important to become a little bit more sophisticated. Go beyond just making interpretations of the behavior to ask yourself, what's going on in the brain and how can we overcome this pathological brain behavior? Do you think that's where the conversations are going in this country about how to treat addictions that we're seeing? I think so. I think there's still an enormous amount of stigma. In general, brain illnesses are more stigmatized compared to other illnesses. But we're making progress. You're probably too young to remember, but there was a time when having cancer was stigmatized.
哇。是的。是的，我不知道那个。是的。如果你的家人中有人患癌症，你会把它掩盖起来。那是一件极其可耻的事情。今天，这看起来完全荒谬。对。绝对是。有所有这些意识项目、步行、筹款活动。电影里有一个场景。实际上是一部伍迪·艾伦的电影。父母在1940年代谈话，母亲说，她得了癌症，只是低声说出来，他们把这变成了一件大事，关于你永远不要大声说出来。是的，没错。所以，我乐观地认为我们会在大脑疾病甚至成瘾方面达到这一点。这需要一点时间，但我认为越来越多的人意识到发生了什么。我告诉你，没有什么比亲身经历或有亲人经历更能帮助人们
Wow. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know that. Yeah. If someone in your family, cancer, you hushed it up. It was an enormously shameful thing. Today, that seems utterly absurd. Right. Absolutely. There's all these awareness programs, walks, fundraisers. There's a scene in a motion picture. It's a Woody Allen picture, actually. And the parents are talking there in the 1940s, and the mother goes, she has cancer and just whispers it and they make a big thing about how you never set it out loud. Yeah, that's right. So, I'm optimistic that we're going to get there with brain diseases and even addictions. It's going to take a little while, but I think that more and more people are realizing what's going on. And I tell you what, there's nothing that helps people
克服污名了。绝对是。这看起来确实推动了潮流。我的意思是，像阿片类药物这样的东西正在影响许多人，朋友、家人，诸如此类。是的，没错。人们说，看，我知道我的儿子是一个好人。然而不知何故，他被困在这个网里。因此，也许我错了。也许这确实不仅仅是道德缺陷。继续谈谈创造力，这总是一个有趣的话题。
overcome stigma better than experiencing it themselves or having a loved one. Absolutely. That's what it seems like it does push the tide more. And I mean, something like opioids is affecting so many people and friends, family, that sort of thing. That's right. People say, look, I know my son is a good person. And yet some somehow he got trapped in this web. Therefore, maybe I was wrong. Maybe this really is something besides a moral failing. And moving on to creativity, which is always a fun topic to talk about.
那么多巴胺在创造性行为中扮演什么角色？在提到那个之前，我想说。你谈到了创造力和疯狂比各自与普通大脑的关系更密切。你能多谈谈那个吗？当然。所以让我回到那个口号。多巴胺的作用是最大化未来的资源。所以多巴胺对已经存在的事物或你已经拥有的事物不感兴趣。
So what is the role of dopamine in creative behavior? And I went just before I mentioned that too. You talked about how creativity and madness are more related than each is to a ordinary brain. Can you talk a little more about that? Sure. So let me just go back to the mantra. The role of dopamine is to maximize future resources. So dopamine is not interested in things that already exist or simply things that you already have.
它总是想要新的东西，更多的东西。这就是它与创造力的联系。它是，你知道，创造力是在以前看起来似乎没有联系的事物之间建立联系。所以多巴胺正在扫描环境，寻找获得新资源的机会。有时这意味着去追求已经存在的资源，但以一种更令人兴奋的方式，有时这意味着创造以前从未存在过的资源。
It always wants something new, something more. And that's its link to creativity. It's, you know, creativity is making connections between things that did not previously seem connected. So dopamine is scanning the environment, looking for opportunities to get new resources. Sometimes that means going after resources that are already there. but in a much more exciting fashion, sometimes it means creating resources that never existed before.
多巴胺能非常强的人在许多情况下很容易分心。他们看到什么，就想知道那是什么。所以有更多的随机事物，我在这里用广泛的术语来说，但有更多的随机事物、概念、图像，无论什么，漂浮在他们的大脑中
Highly dopaminergic people are easily distracted in many cases. They see something, they want to know what it is. And so there are a lot more random things, and I'm speaking in broad terms here, but there are a lot more random things, concepts, images, what have you, floating around in their brains
比非多巴胺能的人或多巴胺水平较低的人。多巴胺。仅仅因为拥有更多的东西，就更有可能关联以前没有关联过的事物。当你刚才说那句话时，丹，我想，如果你正在听这个，你可能会想，好吧，你所说的创造力是什么意思？这是开始理解它的一个好方法。创造力是关联以前没有被普遍关联过的事物。当我在研讨会上谈论这个时，我以布莱恩·威尔逊为例。你听一首歌，他的代表作《美好的振动》。它现在对我们来说太熟悉了，我们没有想太多
than non-dopaminergic people or people with lower levels of dopamine. dopamine. And just by dint of having more things, is more likely to associate things that haven't been associated before. And when you said that a moment ago, Dan, I think that's, if you're listening to this, you're wondering, well, what do you mean by creativity? This is one good way to begin to understand it. Creativity is associating things that have not been commonly associated before. When I talk about this in a seminar, I talk about Brian Wilson as an example. And you listen to a song, his magnum opus, good vibrations. And it's so familiar to us now, we don't think much
关于它。但当你听它时，你会听到，例如，背景中的特雷门琴。那种声音，就像你听到的那样。在那之前，它只被用作恐怖电影中的音效，但布莱恩·威尔逊把它带进来了。你会注意到，在这首三分钟的流行歌曲中，它实际上有三个乐章，就像许多古典作品一样。这个人的大脑里漂浮着太多的东西，他第一次把它们全部整合在一起。如果你听那首歌，然后按这个顺序听，会特别引人注目。你听《美好的振动》之前排名第一的那首歌，然后听《美好的振动》。之前的那首是一首叫《温彻斯特大教堂》的歌，那是杂货店音乐的缩影。
about it. But when you listen to it, you'll hear, for instance, a theremin in the background. That sound like that you're hearing it. Up until that point, that had only been used as a sound effect in horror movies, but Brian Wilson brought it in. You'll notice that in this little three-minute pop song, it actually has three movements like a lot of classical pieces do. There was so much floating around in this man's brain, and he brought it all together for the first time. It's especially striking if you listen to that song and then actually do it in this order. You listen to the song that was number one before Good Vibrations and then listen to Good Vibrations. The one before was a song called Winchester Cathedral, which was the epitome of grocery store music.
关于它。但当你听的时候，你会听到，例如，背景中有一个特雷门琴。你听到的那种声音。在那之前，它只被用作恐怖电影里的音效，但布莱恩·威尔逊把它引入了进来。你会注意到，在这首短短三分钟的流行歌曲中，它实际上像许多古典乐曲一样有三个乐章。这个人的大脑里有太多的想法在涌动，他第一次把它们全部整合在了一起。如果你听了那首歌，然后按这个顺序听，会特别震撼。你先听《Good Vibrations》之前排名第一的歌，然后再听《Good Vibrations》。之前的那首叫《Winchester Cathedral》，那是超市背景音乐的缩影。
Yeah, I've never heard of it. The thing that knocked it out was this wonderful melange of sound. that Brian Wilson created, and he's clearly a highly dopaminergic person who walked that line and fell between creativity and madness. I believe he's been diagnosed with schizophrenia or schizoaffective disorder. Schizophrenia. So, yeah, if I can try to make that connection, let's say you're walking down the street and you see a pebble lying in a puddle. You're probably not going to think anything of it. But if a highly dopaminergic poet is walking down the street and sees that same pebble,
是的，我从来没听说过。让它脱颖而出的是布莱恩·威尔逊创造的那种美妙的声音混合体，他显然是一个多巴胺能水平很高的人，游走在创造力和疯狂的边缘。我相信他被诊断出患有精神分裂症或分裂情感性障碍。精神分裂症。所以，是的，如果我试着建立这种联系，假设你走在街上，看到水坑里有一块鹅卵石。你可能不会多想。但如果一位多巴胺能水平很高的诗人走在街上，看到了同一块鹅卵石，
He may feel that that pebble is speaking to him in a very deep way, that that pebble is revealing something about humanity and the world. He may even feel like that that pebble somehow reveals the hidden divinity of the world, and he may go and write a very beautiful poem about that that inspires dozens of people. Yeah, it's more about inspiration. Yeah, you're talking about, like, you know, these dope me can help with inspiration. He said, making connections. Well, what kind of art is a metaphor?
他可能会觉得那块鹅卵石正在以一种非常深刻的方式对他说话，那块鹅卵石正在揭示关于人类和世界的一些东西。他甚至可能觉得那块鹅卵石以某种方式揭示了世界隐藏的神性，他可能会去写一首非常美丽的诗，激励了许多人。是的，这更多是关于灵感。是的，你谈到的是，你知道，这些多巴胺可以帮助激发灵感。他说，建立联系。那么，什么样的艺术是隐喻呢？
Yeah. Now, I just want to take this poet and I want to turn up his dopamine a little bit more. Now he sees the pebble and instead of metaphorically speaking to him, it's really speaking to him. Instead of revealing divinity of the world, it reveals the fact that he himself is God. Now we've tipped over into mental illness. So having a lot of dopamine can be a very good thing, can be a very exciting thing. But if you have too much, you get a break with reality. There's a splendid demonstration of this, and it involves, again, a famous artist.
是的。现在，我只想带上这位诗人，我想再稍微调高一点他的多巴胺。现在他看到了那块鹅卵石，它不再是隐喻性地对他说话，而是真的在对他说话。它不再是揭示世界的神性，而是揭示了他自己就是上帝的事实。现在我们已经陷入了精神疾病。所以拥有大量的多巴胺可能是一件非常好的事情，可能是一件非常令人兴奋的事情。但如果你拥有太多，你就会与现实脱节。有一个精彩的演示，它再次涉及一位著名的艺术家。
Bob Dylan's subterranean homesick blues. And whether you're familiar with the words or not, I can share very quickly just a few of them. Johnny's in the basement mixing up the medicine. I'm on the pavement thinking about the government. It goes on and on like this. That is one step removed from word salad, which I think is the term you use for when schizophrenics are sort of speaking out of control. Is that, that's right speaking in completely unorganized ways.
鲍勃·迪伦的《地下乡愁蓝调》。无论你是否熟悉歌词，我都可以很快分享其中的几句。约翰尼在地下室混合药物。我在人行道上思考政府。它就这样一直持续下去。这离“词语沙拉”只有一步之遥，我认为这是你用来形容精神分裂症患者那种失控说话的术语。是这样，没错，以完全无组织的方式说话。
And so that's one step away from ink pen, walk it to mommy. Whoa, that's a dog. And I bought sound. Yes. So it's not like the non sequiturs. It's just someone completely not making sense. It's that fine line between, oh, here are these things and I can put them together into something useful.
所以这离“墨水笔，走去妈妈那儿。哇，那是一条狗。我买了声音。”只有一步之遥。是的。所以这不像是不合逻辑的推论。这只是某个人完全说不通。这就是艺术与疯狂之间那条微妙的界限。
And here are these things and they're just going to spill out. That's right. There's a fine line between art and insanity. Sometimes we don't know. Right. Sometimes initially we say, hey, this is crazy. This is not art. And then maybe a few decades later, we take a second look and we say, wait a minute, that is art.
而这些东西只是会溢出来。没错。艺术与疯狂之间有一条微妙的界限。有时我们不知道。对。有时起初我们说，嘿，这太疯狂了。这不是艺术。然后也许几十年后，我们再看一眼，说，等一下，那是艺术。
Yeah, so for people with serious mental illness, I mean, what is dopamine due to someone's brain? And how is that treated? So I think that schizophrenia is the classic illness of too much dopamine. When we scan our environment for things that are important, what we're most interested in is how is it important for me? Let's say that you're sitting at a butt stop killing time and you're reading the newspaper and you're reading about some Canadian trade agreement. Your dopamine is pretty much going to be shut down. Probably.
是的，那么对于患有严重精神疾病的人来说，多巴胺对人的大脑有什么影响？它是如何治疗的？所以我认为精神分裂症是多巴胺过多的典型疾病。当我们扫描环境寻找重要事物时，我们最感兴趣的是它对我有什么重要性？假设你坐在公交车站消磨时间，你在看报纸，你在读关于某个加拿大贸易协定的内容。你的多巴胺很可能会被关闭。大概吧。
Unless you're really in a trade. Yeah, that's right. Canadian trade agreement. Unless you work for a company that trades with Canada. Exactly. Then maybe you are interested. But let's say you read it and all of a sudden you run across the name of somebody you went to school with who's involved in the negotiations.
除非你真的在做贸易。是的，没错。加拿大贸易协定。除非你在一家与加拿大有贸易往来的公司工作。完全正确。那么也许你感兴趣。但假设你读了它，突然你看到了一个你以前同学的名字，他参与了谈判。
You're going to get some dopamine. Yeah. Oh, I know that person. Yes. Okay. Yeah. All right. You're connected to the story. There you go.
你会得到一些多巴胺。是的。哦，我认识那个人。是的。好的。好的。你和这个故事联系起来了。就是这样。
Exactly. Let's say you keep reading and you run across your own name. You're going to get a big surge of dopamine. So dopamine responds to things in the environment that your brain thinks is important to you. Yeah. Now with schizophrenia, we flip the equation. You've got the dopamine circuit going off at inappropriate times. And so what that means is that you may see something that's completely neutral.
完全正确。假设你继续读，你看到了你自己的名字。你会得到一股巨大的多巴胺激增。所以多巴胺会对大脑认为对你重要的环境事物做出反应。是的。现在对于精神分裂症，我们颠倒了这个等式。你的多巴胺回路在不适当的时候被触发了。这意味着你可能会看到一些完全中性的东西。
your dopamine circuit goes off and you develop the mistaken belief that it's about you. You're watching TV and some radio or TV announcer is talking about some CIA spying program. All of a sudden your dopamine circuit goes off for no reason and you developed the idea that the CIA is spying on you. I had a patient who was walking down the street and he saw a stop sign and he developed the belief that his mother had put that there to tell him to stop thinking about women. And we call that paranoia. That's when you interpret things personally that actually have nothing to do with you. Yeah. So the way we treat it is by giving medications that block dopamine.
你的多巴胺回路被触发，你产生了它是关于你的错误信念。你在看电视，某个广播或电视播音员在谈论某个中央情报局的间谍计划。突然你的多巴胺回路无缘无故地被触发，你产生了中央情报局在监视你的想法。我有一个病人走在街上，他看到了一个停车标志，他产生了那是他母亲放的，为了告诉他停止思考女人的信念。我们称之为偏执狂。这就是当你把实际上与你无关的事情进行个人化解读时。是的。所以我们治疗它的方法是给予阻断多巴胺的药物。
Completely? No, not completely. Not completely. And that's part of the art of giving these medications. We want to give just the right dose that the paranoia, the delusions go away, but it doesn't take away all of the patient's enjoyment and motivation in life. It can be a tricky thing to do, but no matter what, a patient's life usually gets dramatically better when they start taking these medications.
完全阻断吗？不，不是完全。不是完全。这也是给予这些药物的艺术的一部分。我们想要给予恰到好处的剂量，让偏执和妄想消失，但它不会夺走病人生活中所有的乐趣和动力。这可能是一件棘手的事情，但无论如何，当病人开始服用这些药物时，他们的生活通常会得到显著改善。
And you were talking about achievement with dopamine, how it helps us push us to this next level. So what is the role of dopamine in making us successful? So I want to talk about how it makes it successful and also how can make us, you know, lie, cheat, steal and do all sorts of bad things, like, you know, commit an act of violence. So to get a sense of what it feels like to have dopamine pushing you along versus trying to go forward without dopamine, think about working on a project that you're incredibly excited about. Typically, it's going to be a project that involves some degree of creativity. I do a little bit of programming.
你刚才谈到了多巴胺带来的成就感，以及它如何帮助我们推动自己达到下一个水平。那么多巴胺在使我们成功方面起什么作用呢？所以我想谈谈它是如何使我们成功的，以及它如何使我们，你知道，撒谎、欺骗、偷窃和做各种坏事，比如，你知道，实施暴力行为。为了了解多巴胺推动你前进的感觉，与没有多巴胺试图前进的感觉相比，想想做一个你非常兴奋的项目。通常，这将是一个涉及某种程度创造力的项目。我做一点编程。
I also love to make PowerPoint presentations. I'm a total nerd. You can do elaborate things with PowerPoint. You can. You can. You see a nice presentation, though. It really captures your attention. It can be boring or could be interesting, right?
我也喜欢制作 PowerPoint 演示文稿。我是一个彻头彻尾的书呆子。你可以用 PowerPoint 做复杂的演示。你可以。你可以。不过你看到一个好的演示文稿。它确实吸引了你的注意力。它可能很无聊，也可能很有趣，对吧？
It is. And I can be working on that and completely lose track of time. I'm excited. I'm happy. I'm fulfilled. That's dopamine pushing me along and it feels fantastic. Alternatively, I may be filling out some paperwork for insurance reimbursement. Yeah.
确实。我可以做那个，完全忘记了时间。我很兴奋。我很高兴。我感到满足。那是多巴胺在推动我前进，感觉棒极了。或者，我可能正在填写一些保险报销的文书工作。是的。
You know, unless I'm going to be getting a whole lot of money, there's no dopamine there. And I've just got to push myself. And I'm looking for any excuse to get away from it. my email, my voicemail messages. So dopamine makes it feel really, really good to pursue things. And that's why sometimes people tell young people, the most important thing is to find your passion. That's another word for the activity that stimulates dopamine. Okay, so that can be something like a job or a hobby or to something immersion.
你知道，除非我能得到一大笔钱，否则那里没有多巴胺。我只是不得不强迫自己。我在寻找任何借口来逃避它。我的电子邮件，我的语音留言。所以多巴胺让追求事物感觉非常好。这就是为什么有时人们告诉年轻人，最重要的事情是找到你的激情。这是刺激多巴胺的活动的另一个词。好的，所以那可以是像工作或爱好或某种沉浸式的东西。
Yeah, something you're immersed in. Yeah, something that's personally meaningful. It doesn't matter what it is. And then also can, but then dopamine can also push us. to by the act of achieving, you might also be hurting other people, correct? Yeah, it can do that. It can make us obsessed with our work and take us away from a personal life. And of course, a work-life balance is very important.
是的，你沉浸其中的东西。是的，个人有意义的东西。它是什么并不重要。然后它也可以，但多巴胺也可以推动我们。通过成就的行为，你可能也在伤害其他人，对吗？是的，它可以那样做。它可以让我们沉迷于工作，让我们远离个人生活。当然，工作与生活的平衡非常重要。
And dopamine can ruin that balance. But it can also prevent us from getting satisfaction from what we're working for so hard. It's never enough. I saw a patient today who is an incredibly successful real estate developer. And he has more money than he will ever be able to spend. And through his life, he's achieved higher and higher and higher levels. But every time he takes a step, he starts comparing himself to the person at the higher level. And his self-esteem is terrible.
多巴胺会破坏这种平衡。但它也可以阻止我们从我们努力工作所追求的东西中获得满足感。永远不够。我今天见了一位病人，他是一位非常成功的房地产开发商。他拥有的钱比他永远能花掉的还要多。在他的一生中，他达到了越来越高的水平。但每次他迈出一步，他就开始把自己和更高水平的人进行比较。他的自尊心很糟糕。
In spite of all of his achievements, in spite of having a wonderful family, he constantly sees himself as a failure because he's always looking for what he has not yet achieved. And that's a pathological behavior of dopamine. Understand, too, that dopamine doesn't say, what's the best way to achieve this goal in a moral way? Yeah. It says, what's the best way to get there? And it falls to us and our development and use of the other neurotransmitters to say, this isn't good. If you're obsessed with winning, anything goes.
尽管他取得了所有的成就，尽管有一个美好的家庭，但他总是把自己看作是一个失败者，因为他总是盯着他还没有实现的目标。这是多巴胺的一种病态行为。还要明白，多巴胺不会说，以道德方式实现这个目标的最好方法是什么？是的。它说，到达那里的最好方法是什么？而我们以及我们对其他神经递质的发展和使用，有责任说，这不好。如果你沉迷于获胜，任何手段都可以。
Right. Unless, I mean, to dopamine, anything goes, unless there's some measure of activity on the other side. That's right. You know, there's two very different ways of looking at what's best. I'm putting the final touches on a paper that looks at the famous trolley problem from the point of view of dopamine. Are you familiar with the trolley? No, I'm not. Yeah.
对。除非，我的意思是，对多巴胺来说，任何手段都可以，除非另一边有某种活动的衡量标准。没错。你知道，看待什么是最好的方式有两种非常不同的方式。我正在为一篇论文做最后的润色，该论文从多巴胺的角度审视了著名的电车难题。你熟悉电车难题吗？不，我不熟悉。是的。
Can you explain it? Yeah. So here's a situation. There's a runaway trolley barreling down the tracks out of control, five workers on the tracks. They can't escape for whatever reason and they're all going to be killed. However, there's a side track. and on that side track is one single worker. And next to you is a switch.
你能解释一下吗？是的。这是一个情况。有一辆失控的电车沿着轨道疾驰，轨道上有五名工人。无论出于什么原因，他们无法逃脱，他们都将被杀死。然而，有一条侧轨。在那条侧轨上有一名工人。你旁边有一个开关。
You can pull that switch, and what pulling the switch will do is divert the train under the sidetrack. So the question is, is it ethically permissible to pull the switch to save five lives at the expense of one? That's a tough question.
你可以拉动那个开关，拉动开关的作用是将火车改道到侧轨上。所以问题是，为了牺牲一个人而挽救五条生命，拉动开关在道德上是允许的吗？这是一个棘手的问题。
Wow, you don't want to be that conductor on that troll. We can make it easier or harder. Now, if you survey people about that, about 90% of people are going to say that it's ethically permissible to pull the switch. And we call that a utilitarian approach to ethics. Maximize future resources. It's very dopaminergic. It's better to save five lives at the expense of one.
哇，你不想成为那辆电车上的列车员。我们可以让它变得更容易或更难。现在，如果你调查人们关于那个问题的情况，大约 90% 的人会说拉动开关在道德上是允许的。我们称之为功利主义的伦理方法。最大化未来的资源。这是非常多巴胺能的。牺牲一个人来挽救五条生命更好。
So this is a situation in which dopamine determines our ethical approach. But let me change the situation slightly. And what my change is going to do is it's going to shift the neurotransmitters you're going to to think about this problem and it's going to change the way you view it. All right. So here's the other way. Trains going down the tracks, five people on the tracks. But now, instead of a side track, you're standing on a bridge next to another man.
所以这是一种多巴胺决定我们伦理方法的情况。但让我稍微改变一下情况。我的改变将要做的，是它将改变你思考这个问题时所使用的神经递质，它将改变你看待它的方式。好的。所以这是另一种方式。火车沿着轨道行驶，轨道上有五个人。但现在，不是侧轨，你站在另一名男子旁边的桥上。
And you know that if you push him onto the tracks, his weight will slow down the train enough to stop it and save the lives of five workers. The question is, is it ethically permissible to push that man? onto the tracks. You survey people about this, and 90% now say, no, it's not ethically permissible to do it. Interesting, but it's still five to one, one to five. Yes.
你知道，如果你把他推到轨道上，他的体重会减慢火车的速度，足以阻止它并挽救五名工人的生命。问题是，把那个人推到轨道上在道德上是允许的吗？你调查人们关于这个的情况，现在 90% 的人说，不，这样做在道德上是不允许的。有趣，但仍然是五比一，一比五。是的。
And the difference is that when you're looking at things from a distance, you tend to use your dopamine circuits. When you look at things up close, you use your hearing now circuits. They follow a different ethical tradition, not utilitarianism, but harm aversion. And Harmor Vision says that it's wrong to hurt people, even if others will benefit from their suffering. Utilitarianism says we should act to save lives.
区别在于，当你从远处看事物时，你倾向于使用你的多巴胺回路。当你近距离看事物时，你使用你的“此时此地”回路。它们遵循不同的伦理传统，不是功利主义，而是伤害厌恶。伤害厌恶说伤害他人是错误的，即使其他人会从他们的痛苦中受益。功利主义说我们应该采取行动挽救生命。
These are both very, very valid ways of approaching a problem. But what's interesting is that depending on the location in three-dimensional space, our brain uses different circuits to process the problem, and we come up with different solutions. Wow, this sounds very complex. It's hard to believe this is all happening in our... Well, it has profound implications for drone warfare. How do you program the machine? If you're going to be purely utilitarian, the answer's easy, but then you have to deal with the aftermath. There was even a film about, I'm sorry, I forget the name, we talk about it in the book.
这些都是处理问题的非常、非常有效的方法。但有趣的是，根据在三维空间中的位置，我们的大脑使用不同的回路来处理问题，我们得出了不同的解决方案。哇，这听起来非常复杂。很难相信这一切都在我们的……嗯，它对无人机战争有深远的影响。你如何编程机器？如果你要纯粹功利主义，答案很简单，但随后你必须处理后果。甚至有一部关于它的电影，对不起，我忘了名字，我们在书中谈到了它。
This really is a problem today. And it has to be answered one way or the other. There's no middle ground here. I think what the film looked at was that they were going to kill some terrorists who were planning a plot that was going to blow up a stadium. But in order to do that, they were going to have to also kill an innocent child. Right. And the question was, should we save the hundreds of lives in the stadium at the expense of intentionally murdering this innocent child? And it's an updated version of the trolley problem. And I think it's interesting to note that if you hear about it or
这确实是今天的一个问题。它必须以某种方式得到回答。这里没有中间地带。我认为电影审视的是，他们要杀死一些正在策划炸毁体育场的阴谋的恐怖分子。但为了做到这一点，他们还必须杀死一个无辜的孩子。对。问题是，我们应该牺牲故意谋杀这个无辜孩子的代价来挽救体育场里的数百条生命吗？这是电车难题的更新版本。我认为值得注意的是，如果你听说它，或者
if you see it on a screen or if you're touching, every level that increases that here and now participation makes the problem harder. So you think it'd be more difficult if you're sitting somewhere remotely conducting using a drone as opposed to being flying a plane or something? Easier. Easier. Easier. Easier. It would be easier to program the drone to say take out the terrorists and the children. Yeah. Then it would be if you were standing right there on location, let's say with a gun and you were told pull the trigger, but you've got to shoot through the child to get the terrorist. In fact, the easiest of all is to program the drone to do it because there's nobody involved at all. Everything is hypothetical.
如果你在屏幕上看到它，或者如果你在触摸它，每一层增加那种“此时此地”参与度的东西都会使问题变得更难。所以你认为如果你坐在某个遥远的地方使用无人机指挥，而不是驾驶飞机或类似的东西，会更困难吗？更容易。更容易。更容易。更容易。编程无人机说消灭恐怖分子和孩子会更容易。是的。比如果你站在现场，比如说拿着枪，被告知扣动扳机，但你必须穿过孩子射击才能击中恐怖分子。事实上，最容易的是编程无人机来做这件事，因为根本没有人在场。一切都是假设的。
It's a pattern that you're dealing with, not particulars. So the easiest of all is to program a drone to take the utilitarian answer because you don't have to feel anything when you write code. This may never be used first. Yeah, right. But you hope it never does. I mean, it's very complicated. It is. Yeah.
你处理的是一种模式，而不是细节。所以最容易的是编程无人机采取功利主义的答案，因为当你编写代码时，你不需要感觉到任何东西。这可能永远不会首先被使用。是的，对。但你希望它永远不会。我的意思是，这非常复杂。确实。是的。
Our brains are complicated. In a way, it's complicated. In a way, it's gut-twistingly simple. Or here's another simple question. How should self-driving cars be programmed? Let's say that your self-driving car is going to get in an accident. Should it be programmed to minimize loss of life? Or should it be programmed to save the life of its owner?
我们的大脑很复杂。在某种程度上，它很复杂。在某种程度上，它简单得令人揪心。或者这里有另一个简单的问题。自动驾驶汽车应该如何编程？假设你的自动驾驶汽车要发生事故。它应该被编程为最大限度地减少生命损失吗？还是应该被编程为挽救其所有者的生命？
Oh. It's a difficult question. Yeah, because right now a car is just, obviously, it's not programmed. Well, the driver decides. Yeah. And instinctually, what we do is we drive to protect ourselves. And that's something we have no control over. Yeah, just make a supposed to like a decision.
哦。这是一个困难的问题。是的，因为现在汽车只是，显然，它没有被编程。嗯，司机决定。是的。本能地，我们所做的是我们驾驶以保护自己。这是我们无法控制的事情。是的，只是做一个假设的决定。
We will swerve into a crowd of people if we think it's going to save her own life. And it's not a decision we make. It's, but with self-driving cars, that becomes a decision we need to make as we program it. And it's very difficult decision and nobody's talking about it too much. There's a lot of interesting ethical, you know, as we get more removed by using technology, some interesting ethical issues that come into play. But yeah, you mentioned about winning. So I'm winning in morality.
如果我们认为这会挽救我们自己的生命，我们会转向人群。这不是我们做出的决定。它是，但对于自动驾驶汽车，这变成了我们需要在编程时做出的决定。这是一个非常困难的决定，没有人谈论它太多。随着我们通过使用技术变得更加疏远，出现了一些有趣的伦理问题。但是是的，你提到了关于获胜。所以我正在赢得道德。
I think that leads me to my next question about politics. So how is dopamine involved in politics? And does it affect whether we're liberal, conservative, or moderate? When I was researching the book, this was the thing that surprised me the most. It never occurred to me that political ideology could be so influenced by brain chemistry. We can figure out who's more dopaminergic and who's more. here and now simply by looking at the labels that are attached to the different parties. The left calls themselves progressives.
我认为这引出了我关于政治的下一个问题。那么多巴胺是如何参与政治的呢？它是否影响我们是自由派、保守派还是温和派？当我研究这本书时，这是最让我惊讶的事情。我从来没有想到政治意识形态会受到大脑化学物质如此大的影响。我们可以通过查看不同政党所贴的标签，找出谁更多是多巴胺能的，谁更多是“此时此地”的。左派称自己为进步派。
They're interested in progress. They want to make the world a better place. And that's maximizing future resources. And so they're interested in things like taking control, helping people to live healthier, longer lives by making it difficult for them to access unhealthy food or tobacco or alcohol or things like that. And so they're very much about taking control of things to maximize the goodness. The right on the other side, they call themselves conservatives. They're much less interested in change. They're much less interested in things that are new. They're more here and now.
他们对进步感兴趣。他们想让世界变得更美好。这就是最大化未来的资源。所以他们对诸如控制、通过使人们难以获得不健康的食物或烟草或酒精等东西来帮助人们过上更健康、更长寿的生活之类的事情感兴趣。所以他们非常热衷于控制事物以最大化善良。右派在另一边，他们称自己为保守派。他们对改变的兴趣要小得多。他们对新事物的兴趣要小得多。他们更多是“此时此地”。
They want to preserve the things they've valued that they've inherited from their forebears. And so they're much less likely to have active dopaminergic circuits. And we can look at genetics. And we can actually predict a person's political ideology by looking at their dopamine genes. Well, that's fascinating. Not only that, but we can actually shift people to the left or the right by surreptitiously influencing what parts of their brain are going to be more active. So, for example, if you are under threat, that's going to activate your here and now circuits because you need to protect what you already have.
他们想保留他们从祖先那里继承下来的他们所珍视的东西。所以他们不太可能有活跃的多巴胺能回路。我们可以看看遗传学。我们实际上可以通过观察一个人的多巴胺基因来预测他们的政治意识形态。嗯，这太迷人了。不仅如此，我们实际上可以通过秘密地影响他们大脑的哪些部分将更加活跃，从而将人们推向左派或右派。所以，例如，如果你受到威胁，那将激活你的“此时此地”回路，因为你需要保护你已经拥有的东西。
So it's this fascinating experiment in which they surveyed people about their political ideology and they randomized them. In one, they put a hand sanitizer dispenser in the room as a very subtle reminder of the risk of infection. The simple presence of that hand sanitizer pushed people to be more conservative in their answers to the survey. That's interesting. Yeah, I mean, I guess what I'm just thinking about.
所以这是一个迷人的实验，他们调查了人们的政治意识形态并将他们随机分组。在其中一个房间里，他们放了一个洗手液分配器，作为对感染风险的非常微妙的提醒。洗手液的简单存在促使人们在调查回答中更加保守。这很有趣。是的，我的意思是，我想我只是在思考。
Can you, so as you're saying, it's like less about persuasion and like trying to bring someone to your side and more about some of the chemicals in our brains? Unfortunately, that seems to be the case. And politicians know this. We know that when there is a terrorist attack or any kind of threat to the country, it pushes people to the right. We also know that when there's the possibility of prosperity, it pushes people to the left. And so the saying is to provide or protect. Provide is more to the left. Let's make this country a better place. Let's progress more. Protect is more to the right.
你能，正如你所说，这更少关于说服和试图把某人带到你这边，更多关于我们大脑中的一些化学物质？不幸的是，情况似乎就是这样。政治家们知道这一点。我们知道，当发生恐怖袭击或对国家有任何形式的威胁时，它会把人们推向右派。我们也知道，当有繁荣的可能性时，它会把人们推向左派。所以说法是提供或保护。提供更多是向左。让我们让这个国家变得更美好。让我们进步更多。保护更多是向右。
Let's maintain the good things that we have. And that's more here and now neurotransmitters. And can you increase or decrease the amount of dopamine you have? I mean, you said a lot of it's determined by genetics. And, you know, thinking, not a person who's affected by a serious mental illness, but for a general person, can you increase that? Everybody wants to increase their dopamine. And that's dopamine at work.
让我们保持我们拥有的好东西。而那是更多的“此时此地”神经递质。你能增加或减少你拥有的多巴胺量吗？我的意思是，你说很多是由遗传决定的。而且，你知道，思考，不是一个受严重精神疾病影响的人，但对于一个普通人，你能增加它吗？每个人都想增加他们的多巴胺。这就是多巴胺在起作用。
Yeah. Right? more more more yeah so the answer is yes you can increase your dopamine but it's a dangerous thing to do okay because i read an article that said you can eat more protein exercise and sleep more is like is that even true that's just good advice yeah i'm really containing a healthy lifestyle but i was like that seems a little simplistic you're saying it's it's not as easy as that no it's not you know that might influence your dopamine a tiny bit probably not enough to have an effect on you um drugs like pain amphetamine.
是的。对吧？更多更多更多是的，所以答案是是的，你可以增加你的多巴胺，但这是一件危险的事情，因为我读过一篇文章说你可以吃更多的蛋白质、锻炼和多睡觉，这是真的吗？那只是好的建议。是的，我确实包含了一种健康的生活方式，但我当时想那看起来有点简单。你说它不像那样容易。不，它不是，你知道，那可能会对你的多巴胺产生一点点影响，可能不足以对你产生影响，嗯，像苯丙胺这样的药物。
Okay. So not good things. Things we don't want to do. Things we don't want to do. Okay. And so, you know, people will take amphetamine and it will make them work harder. It will make them more excited. It will focus them in on being goal directed, but eventually will also ruin their life.
好的。所以不是好东西。我们不想做的事情。我们不想做的事情。好的。所以，你知道，人们会服用苯丙胺，它会让他们工作更努力。它会让他们更兴奋。它会让他们专注于目标导向，但最终也会毁了他们的生活。
So artificially boosting dopamine is not the best strategy for a successful life. And just to be technical for a minute, it doesn't actually increase the volume of dopamine and increases the dopaminergic activity across the cells, right? Yes. Right, it increases the amount of dopamine that's active at any given point in time. But that's basically by farrying it from an inactive place to an active place. Right, right. It's not an increase in the volume of dopamine.
所以人为地提升多巴胺不是成功生活的最佳策略。为了技术一点，它实际上并没有增加多巴胺的体积，它增加了细胞间的多巴胺能活性，对吧？是的。对，它增加了在任何给定时间点活跃的多巴胺量。但这基本上是通过将其从不活跃的地方运送到活跃的地方。对，对。这不是多巴胺体积的增加。
It's an increase in the activity associated with the dopamine you already have. That's right. In the same way an antidepressant can work. Now, there are some illnesses that are characterized by problematically low levels of dopamine. And for example, attention deficit disorder. And in that case, it is appropriate to prescribe something like amphetamine, which boosts the activity of dopamine. And that's a very safe. Like a riddlein? Riddle. Okay. Yeah. Or Adderall. Yeah. People abuse that as well to say,
这是与你已经拥有的多巴胺相关的活动的增加。没错。以抗抑郁药起作用的同样方式。现在，有些疾病的特征是多巴胺水平低得有问题。例如，注意力缺陷障碍。在这种情况下，开像苯丙胺这样的药物是适当的，它会提升多巴胺的活性。那是一个非常安全的。像利他林？利他林。好的。是的。或者阿得拉。是的。人们也滥用它来，你知道，
goal-oriented focus. They do. They do. Parkinson's disease is also an illness of too little dopamine. And we prescribed dopaminergic drugs to treat that too. And in our book, we mentioned how that that can be very effective for Parkinson's symptoms, but it can also get people into trouble. Yeah, that was an interesting part of when you're talking about how it can lead people to have a much higher interest in sex and gambling. Gambling. Yeah, gambling. It's fascinating. There's been some case reports of people who have been completely abstinent from sex their entire life. They're treated with these drugs, and all of a sudden, they become compulsively sexual. There's also examples, though, of people developing artistic and poetic talent as a result of getting these dopamine boosting drugs.
目标导向的专注。他们确实。他们确实。帕金森病也是一种多巴胺过少的疾病。我们也开多巴胺能药物来治疗它。在我们的书中，我们提到了这对于帕金森症状可能非常有效，但它也可能让人陷入麻烦。是的，那是当你谈论它如何导致人们对性和赌博有更高兴趣时的一个有趣部分。赌博。是的，赌博。这很迷人。有一些病例报告显示，有些人一生中完全禁欲。他们接受这些药物治疗，突然之间，他们变得强迫性地性欲旺盛。然而，也有人因获得这些多巴胺提升药物而发展出艺术和诗歌天赋的例子。
This is probably something that's studied in psychiatry a lot or, you know, in the medical field. It's a fun area of study. Yeah, that sounds absolutely fascinating. So can we control dopamine to use to our advantage and not to our peril? The ultimate question. We can. You know, one of the oldest pieces of wisdom can be found at the Greek oracle of Delphi, and that is know thyself.
这可能是精神病学中研究很多的东西，或者，你知道，在医学领域。这是一个有趣的研究领域。是的，这听起来绝对迷人。那么我们能控制多巴胺来利用它为我们服务，而不是让我们陷入危险吗？终极问题。我们可以。你知道，最古老的智慧之一可以在德尔斐的希腊神谕中找到，那就是认识你自己。
If you know what's going on in your brain, you don't have to be a slave to it. You can say, I'm experiencing cravings or I'm experiencing dissatisfaction. And maybe it's not because of the reality I'm living in. Maybe it's because of the way my brain is responding to reality. And that allows us to take a step back. We call it the observing ego to sort of step back and look at how we're responding and say, is this the best way to respond? Or do I want to maybe act contrary to my biology and make a different kind of decision?
如果你知道你的大脑里发生了什么，你就不必成为它的奴隶。你可以说，我正在经历渴望，或者我正在经历不满。也许这不是因为我所生活的现实。也许是因为我的大脑对现实做出反应的方式。这使我们能够退后一步。我们称之为观察自我，退后一步，看看我们是如何反应的，并说，这是最好的反应方式吗？或者我是否想也许违背我的生物学并做出不同种类的决定？
So I think that knowing and being able to recognize when your dopamine circuit's active, when you're here and now circuits active, and is this really the way you want to behave, that's what's going to empower you. I'll add just this because that's right on the nose. If you're aware that there are two ways to anticipate or to experience the world, to anticipate it or to experience it and to learn which one is the trouble. point for you. For most people, probably most people listening to this podcast, it's going to be on the dopaminergic side. Anticipation. Yes, anticipation. To cultivate your ability to just experience where you are. To put the simple things like put the phone down during dinner, turn it off. When you're talking to somebody, look in their eyes and listen to what they say. Don't worry about what you're going to say next. Listen to it. Be here now, as the phrase goes.
所以我认为知道并能够识别你的多巴胺回路何时活跃，你的“此时此地”回路何时活跃，以及这真的是你想要的行为方式吗，这就是将赋予你力量的东西。我只会补充这一点，因为这正中要害。如果你意识到有两种方式来预期或体验世界，去预期它或去体验它，并学习哪一个是你的麻烦点。对于大多数人，可能大多数听这个播客的人，它将是在多巴胺能的一侧。预期。是的，预期。去培养你只是体验你所在位置的能力。去做简单的事情，比如在晚餐时放下手机，关掉它。当你和某人交谈时，看着他们的眼睛，听他们说什么。不要担心你接下来要说什么。听它。此时此地，正如那句话所说。
the simple awareness that this exists at all is a profound gift that you can give yourself. And the irony is that when people do that, they talk about how much they enjoy it, and yet they do it so little because their dopamine circuits are saying, don't waste your time. Yeah. Think ahead. And the good news is this is a choice anyone can make. Yeah.
这种存在本身就是一种深刻的礼物，你可以给自己。讽刺的是，当人们这样做时，他们谈论他们有多么享受它，然而他们做得如此之少，因为他们的多巴胺回路在说，不要浪费你的时间。是的。向前思考。好消息是这是一个任何人都可以做出的选择。是的。
And this is what we're seeing with this emphasis on mindfulness and people wanting to be here and now. I think because we are living in a world that's very, dopamine-centric, you know, with constant, you know, instant gratification all the time. So that's where I imagine, this is me just editorializing, but where we're seeing this boom and mindfulness in that country, yeah. We really do have it off. We don't need a new cell phone. We don't need a bigger TV. We need to just experience what we have and enjoy it. So I do have one last question for you. Where can people find your book? You can go to moleculeofmore.com to read more about it. You can get it Amazon or anywhere such excellent books are sold.
这就是我们所看到的对正念的强调，以及人们想要此时此地的愿望。我认为因为我们生活在一个非常以多巴胺为中心的世界里，你知道，一直有不断的即时满足。所以这就是我所想象的，这是我只是在发表社论，但我们在那个国家看到这种正念繁荣的地方，是的。我们确实把它关掉了。我们不需要新手机。我们不需要更大的电视。我们需要只是体验我们拥有的东西并享受它。所以我确实有一个最后一个问题要问你。人们在哪里可以找到你的书？你可以去 moleculeofmore.com 阅读更多关于它的信息。你可以在亚马逊或任何销售此类优秀书籍的地方买到它。
Absolutely. And in 10 countries, I think, by the end of 2020. And translate into new languages? Nine languages. Wow, that's amazing. Thank you so much for joining us. This has been an absolutely fascinating conversation. Thank you, Caitlin.
绝对。而且在 10 个国家，我想，到 2020 年底。并翻译成新语言？九种语言。哇，那太棒了。非常感谢你加入我们。这是一次绝对迷人的谈话。谢谢你，凯特琳。
It's been a pleasure. Thank you. If you've been a long-time listener or are new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. And if you have time, write a review. We'd really appreciate it. Also, we'd like to hear from you directly. So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas to share,
这是我的荣幸。谢谢。如果你是一位长期听众或者是我们播客的新手，请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分。如果你有时间，写一篇评论。我们将非常感激。此外，我们想直接听取你的意见。所以如果你有任何问题、评论或想法要分享，
please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's KLUNA at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes the podcast's APA Journal's dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
请发电子邮件给我，地址是 K-Luna at APA.org。那是 KLUNA at APA.org。《心理学谈话》是 APA 播客网络的一部分，其中包括播客《APA 期刊对话》关于新的心理学研究，以及《进度记录》关于心理学实践。你可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。
You can also visit our website, Speaking of Psychology.org, to listen to more episodes and to see resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也可以访问我们的网站 Speaking of Psychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看我们讨论主题的资源。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。